à quelques minutes de leur première
apparition au côté des Templiers les
cheer leaders profinent leur
chorégraphie au menu pyramides humaines
sopérieux et figure en tout genre autant
dire que l'on s'improvise pas cheers il
faut être
motivé danseuse gymnaste enfin prête à
avoir des sensations
gé de 16 à 25 ans Alison Cindy Laor et
les si autres cheers ont presque tout un
passé de danseuse ou de gymnastes des
passions communes qui ont renforcé la
cohésion de l' éip créé en septembre
dernier et dévooué au Templiers il faut
en fait encourager les joueurs sans les
gêner le public penser au public
euh faire faire des tas de choses pour
que pour pour que tout se passe bien
pour que le match soit un petit peu
comme en Amérique on est un peu comme
une petite une petite famille déjà bah
l'ambiance des
Templiers nous aide à rentrer dans ce
dans cette ambiance là lors de cette
rencontre entre les Templiers et les SOR
le thermomètre affiche des températures
sous les 0 degr pas de quoi décourager
les cheers qui assurent quand même le
spectacle au bord du terrain
[Applaudissements]
elles auront le droit elles aussi à leur
compétition puisquelles vont participer
cette saison au challenge régional des
cheers